au pied de ces tours de la cité des
indes à sartrouville pierrot s'activent
il doit assurer une livraison de repas
aux personnels soignants du chu
d'argenteuil
le jeune homme et d'autres riverains
réunis dans un collectif de citoyens
créé en juillet dernier se sont mis à
pied d'oeuvre dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie de coronavirus a décidé de
solliciter les commerçants de
sartrouville en premier lieu
nous mettre à disposition des paniers
repas qu'on emmènerait par la suite au
personnel hospitalier
donc les commerçants ont tout de suite
je vais le jeu juste des intermédiaires
et nous on n'apporte que l'upl il ya un
grand frère aussi de sartrouville qui
qui est dans le bâtiment et qui a décidé
de faire don d'un d'un sac rempli de
masque on voit la presse et chacun a sa
part à son échelle les seuils de de
soutenir le personnel hospitalier
le personnel hospitalier pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est celle des personnes
qui sont qui sont vraiment au front face
à l'épidémie
c'est vraiment les personnes qui sont là
pour pour soigner les citoyens et et qui
sont vraiment voilà exposés aux
violences
chaque jour aux alentours de 13 heures
le collectif post une vidéo sur les
réseaux sociaux
un appel aux restaurateurs des alentours
qui souhaitent participer à l'opération
grand frère et soeur de sartrouville
sont encore argenteuil à au chu
d'argenteuil et cette fois ci pour
apporter des blues tu ne m'as une maman
très généreuse nous à nous a offert et
on la remercie pour ça merci énormément
on encourage on encourage on encourage
chaque citoyen chaque commerçant tout le
monde à soutenir le personnel
hospitalier
c'est eux qui sont au front comme je le
dis et je le répète c'est eux qui
doivent être soutenus ce lundi s'est
fait chair rabat qui a répondu présent
il va offrir au collectif une vingtaine
de sandwichs pour ce commerçant il était
inimaginable de ne pas participer à
cette opération de solidarité
on voulait absolument exclue donc il
donne à coup moi et puis la préparer
tous les sandwichs assez souvent on fait
ce qu'on peut c'est pas grand chose mais
voilà mais ça ne donne aucunement
renouvellera cette séparation
on pouvait pas rester les bras croisés
face aux aides-soignants face au docteur
face à tout le monde qui est qui qui
diront que le clan trampoline clients je
souffre le premier pour une fois les
sandwichs et chargé à bord de leur
camionnette rouge
pierrot et son ami prennent la direction
du chu d'argenteuil la solidarité avant
tout c'est même une frappe hernie mais
enfin quand on va au service des
urgences pour leur donner justement que
par la suite de la pluie
on essaie de la faim tous les jours on
les fait deux
manger bas aux différents services qui a
sur l'hôpital et en vrai
un vrai sentiment de 2
le chercher quand on la porte parce
qu'on est vraiment remercier fin mai
plus en plus de ses livraisons le
collectif a aussi lancé l'opération
kinto rôle ils nettoient les halls des
immeubles leur façon à eux de soutenir
les femmes de ménage pendant cette
période et de tenter de limiter la
propagation du virus
un message aussi pour montrer les
quartiers sous un angle positif
loin des clichés parfois relayées